we are yet another step closer to wiping
out Obama era online privacy laws in the
craziness and the cartoony nonsense of
Trump Republicans continue to do real
damage and it's important for us to
cover not only the Trump scandals but
also what Republicans are doing and
we've been doing that Congress has now
sent the proposed legislation that would
allow among other things internet
service providers to sell your browsing
history to advertisers not only has the
Senate voted in favor of these rules the
house has voted in favor of these rules
and now it goes to President Donald
Trump earlier this week the story was
the Senate voted to let ISPs sell your
browsing history to advertisers now the
house has also voted in favor and it
goes to Trump's desk and if Donald Trump
signed the legislation I said earlier
this week maybe Trump wouldn't sign it
what I'm hearing now Pat is that more
than likely Trump is going to sign it
this will allow internet service
providers to monitor customers online
behavior it would allow them to without
permission use personal and financial
information of their customers to sell
very highly targeted ads search engines
and streaming video sites are already
collecting a lot of this usage data and
what we would be allowed now would be
the sale of this data and the use of
this data by advertisers and in a number
of other ways and obviously any advocate
for privacy protection is saying that
this is a disastrous setback for the
United States in terms of Internet
privacy law the funniest quote I found
about this is from cuckoo Republican
Marsha Blackburn she said sit down for
this she said consumer privacy will be
enhanced by removing the uncertainty and
confusion that these rules were create
yeah now it'll be completely clear that
all of your data including browsing data
is being sold to advertisers whereas
before maybe you weren't sure that it
was being sold what kind of an
explanation what kind of support is that
to say now there will be no doubt as to
what internet service providers
providers are doing with your data this
is the weakest
offense of this that I've heard they
always try to just flip it to make it
sound like a good thing and we're in a
really bad position when Donald Trump is
our last hope is right but who knows he
made to choose not to sign it because he
was elected as a populist he doesn't
really have any direct stake in this I
would say but also on the other hand
maybe he's trying to appease his
Republican base a little bit more
especially after the defeat of their
Obamacare repeal effort so we'll see who
knows at this point what he'll do he is
against net neutrality he doesn't
understand what it is he once said
something like net neutrality is the
fairly Fairness Doctrine and I'm against
it right it was completely clueless
statement but he knows enough to know
that he's against it why it's not clear
also on Marsha Blackburn Marsha
Blackburn has received nearly seven
hundred thousand dollars from the ISP
cable industry and their associated
lobbyists she has not done anything in
recent years that would go against the
desires of the phone lobby the cable
lobby and the isp lobby not a single
Democrat voted for this bill in either
the house or the Senate this is the
power of having a majority in both
houses and in the White House and for
all of the Trump executive orders that
don't really do anything Republicans in
the House and Senate are doing real
damage and oftentimes we'll get emails
from people saying David both parties
are the same or we'll get emails from
people saying David the Republicans
can't do anything right and the
Democrats are doing everything right the
truth is somewhere in between the truth
is not that both parties are the same
that's very clear because we saw a one
hundred percent party line vote on this
every Republican voting in favor of this
other than a couple of Republicans in
the Senate I believe who didn't vote at
all every Democrat voting against it
that's a major difference between
Democrats and Republicans so don't fall
for the falsely dichotomous view that
you either have a great party and a
terrible party or that both parties are
the same the truth is on many issues
there's not a real practical operational
difference between Democrats and
Republicans but there are also major
differences between Democrats and
seconds on important issues and that's
why it's too bad that this most recent
election came down to Donald Trump
versus Hillary Clinton yeah where you
know the Democrat versus Republican
angle is really much more important
because that determined who's going to
have power over the entire executive
branch yeah and if you vote for let's
say a Republican for president you're
more likely to vote for Republicans in
the Senate and Congress and they took
over every single one of those branches
houses rather an important practical
question are there practical steps you
can take as a consumer to increase your
online privacy I genuinely am unsure
initially people were emailing me saying
David you're going to want to use a VPN
a virtual private network for browsing
but I read more and more that that may
not really protect you and basically
instead of your internet service
provider having a list of web sites you
visited it will be the VPN that has that
list and you need to trust the VPN and a
lot of websites won't work through a VPN
Netflix for example tries to block all
traffic from VPN so that's one
possibility that may not actually be the
panacea that some believe it to be
others emailed me saying David you
should be using tor to browse the
internet because it anonymized is your
internet use by routing your browsing
through multiple servers around the
world but wired has an article saying
that that may actually not be as
effective as some people believe so
bottom line I don't really know what
there is that the individual consumer
can definitively do what about the
incognito mode on google chrome
frequently and the rising history yeah i
know if um you empty your browsing
history if your internet service
provider already has your browsing
history you can empty the local browsing
history but your isp already has it an
incognito mode is not meant but that is
unclad you brought that up incognito
mode does not hide what you're doing
from your internet service provider it
can hide some of your information or
block cookies and tracking information
from the website that you're visiting
but your ISP will still have the data so
it's bad at all we're screwed yeah well
I think that we maybe it's it's pretty
bad out there if your congressperson
voted for this bill start calling and
tell them that they have lost your vote
and there are
number of discussions about this on our
reddit discussion forum which you can
join at david pakman.com slash our EDD
IT today's episode of the david pakman
show is made possible in part by Warby
Parker I glasses Warby Parker recently
did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five day home
try-on from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription
into I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like an
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses with Warby Parker
they started just 95 bucks mine cost
that including lenses and for every pair
sold they give a pair to someone in need
so to try the five pairs and support the
david pakman show go to Warby Parker
trial com /t DPS